bonjour et bienvenue dans europe hebdo
au parlement européen ici à bruce dans
cette émission retour à l'aquila en
italie victime d'un tremblement de terre
en 2009
trois ans après les ruines sont toujours
là mais tout de suite l'espace schengen
après un an de discussions et bien la
réforme est en train d'aboutir schengen
la décision a été prise en 1985
l'application de schengen c'est 1995 ça
fait donc dix sept ans 17 ans et ça ne
fonctionne pas par ces quelques mots
nicolas sarkozy invitait schengen dans
la campagne présidentielle
un traité en panne une réforme
indispensable
à la clé une volonté de rétablir les
contrôles aux frontières en cas
d'immigration massive
face à cela comme souvent les voisins
européens s'agace la réforme de l'espace
schengen est déjà en cours et la
réplique fuse schengen n'est pas un
outil pour gérer les migrations
une fois de plus l'europe est source de
tous les maux et bouc émissaire des
politiques
quelques semaines après sa défaite et
l'arrivée au pouvoir de françois
hollande la page est définitivement
tournée
l'afflux de clandestins ne peut plus
être un levier pour rétablir le contrôle
aux frontières
seuls subsistent les circonstances
d'exceptionnel
les circonstances d'exceptionnel vaste
flou pour preuve alors que son président
assure qu'il n'y a aucun problème de
sécurité
voilà que c'est la pologne qui rétablit
le contrôle aux frontières
motif euro de football circonstances
exceptionnelles alors l'espace schengen
et emilien passe
alors pour parler de la réforme de
schengen nous avons été rejoints par
sylvie guillaume bonjour vous êtes
eurodéputée française vous êtes vice
présidente du groupe socialiste ici au
parlement européen
est ce qu'on peut dire que ça y est on
est en train d'aboutir justement à cette
réforme de l'espace schengen qui a été
lancée maintenant il ya à peu près un an
il ya plusieurs dossiers sur la réforme
de schengen ya à la fois la réforme du
mécanisme de surveillance et
d'évaluation ce qui se passe à
l'intérieur de schengen et puis il ya
cette réflexion en cours sur doit-on ou
pas et à quel moment avec quelle sur
quelle occasion fermer les frontières
intérieures donc oui on est en train de
progresser
je trouve et le sujet ne le disait très
bien que la manière dont a été abordé le
sujet schengen c'était pas seulement une
question de campagne électorale mais
c'était aussi saisir l'opportunité du
printemps arabe et de ses suites pour
amalgamer un certain nombre de notions
effectivement schengen c'est la libre
circulation des personnes c1 et plus
d'un milliard de trajet de transfert
tous les ans ça n'est pas un moyen de
régler les ch'timis date est ce que
cette réforme de schengen est toujours
je dirais nécessaire dans le sens où la
france et l'allemagne mais surtout la
france avec nicolas sarkozy on entendu
était à la pointe pour cette réforme
entre temps on l'a tous noté il ya eu un
changement de président de la république
la position française déjà
considérablement changé dès le début on
pouvait se poser la question de savoir
si cette réforme était nécessaire
nous avons eu il ya quelques jours la
délivrance d'une sorte de bulletin de
situation de schengen par la commission
qui montre que certes les mécanismes
doivent être plus performants
il doit y avoir une meilleure fluidité
une année meilleure surveillance mais
que globalement il n'y a pas de graves
faiblesses dans schengen
à l'heure actuelle il ya des points de
difficulté les frontières européennes
les frontières de schengen ne sont pas
des passoires
non il y a des points de fragilité dans
des endroits très précis puisque ce que
dit par exemple 7
ce bulletin de situation c'est que sur
le trimestre dernier trimestre 2011
il y a eu les trois quarts des
franchissements 30 mines franchissement
annuelle qui se sont passés par la
frontière gréco turque
donc il y a des points de fragilité il
ya aussi un point de fragilité vers
lampedusa mais l'idée ce n'est pas en
fermant des frontières intérieures que
nous arriverons à aider les pays qui
sont aux frontières extérieures et c'est
donc la solidarité à mettre en oeuvre
vis-à-vis de ces pays là qu'il faut
qu'il faut arriver à à renforcer et pas
des herses a levé dans des pays qui ne
sont pas frapper directement par les
frontières extérieures
qu'est ce qui va changer dans le
schengen version ainsi on peut dire
schengen vers son de ckoi la différence
à grand chose parce que justement c'est
qu'ils étaient mis en exergue c'était
une part cette référence aux flux
migratoires importants donc ce que le
parlement a dit très fermement
c'est que le motif de pression
migratoire ne pouvait pas être
considérée comme un motif valable de
fermeture des frontières extérieures et
la deuxième chose c'est aussi le côté
communautaire de la décision sur
lesquels il ya une vraie bagarre à
l'institutionnel je pense que évidemment
sur la sécurité intérieure les états
membres ont une vision à faire valoir
c'est tout à fait juste
mais pas sur n'importe quel sujet est
donc une sorte de supervision est
communautarisation de la décision de
partage de la décision aussi entre
plusieurs états membres concernés est
absolument nécessaire au cours de cette
réforme les circonstances
exceptionnelles elles existent déjà
donc il y aura peu de modifications sur
ce sujet donc on est un peu de temps tu
est effectivement de se dire tout ça
pour ça et est ce que les vrais enjeux
les vrais enjeux des frontières
extérieures et vrais enjeux de pertes de
vies
les vrais enjeux de pression sur des
pays qui sont aux frontières de l'union
et qui ont des difficultés à gérer les
choses sans vraiment prise en compte et
est ce que le problème de fond c'est les
entrées par les frontières extérieures
ce problème de l'immigration clandestine
en europe
ou est ce que c'est des gens qui
arrivent tout à fait légalement par les
aéroports et qui ensuite ne reporte pas
la majorité de la création de situation
irrégulière en europe est effectivement
lié au phénomène de vignes et de décrire
qui est des personnes on rentre avec un
visa de court séjour
tu restes et donc de vienne sont ensuite
en situation irrégulière mais c'est vrai
qu'il ya une pression aussi une
immigration clandestine moi je serais
tenté de dire que si les états membres
doivent se soucier de quelque chose en
particulier c'est aussi de cela parce
que c'est aussi le fait de passeurs de
réseau qui met la vie de personnes en
danger et que c'est sans doute là avec
le trafic d'êtres humains
il faut être les plus efficaces schengen
était à la une de l'actualité européenne
pendant de longs mois
aujourd'hui c'est en train de s'achever
cette période a vraiment puisque si on
s'en tient aux dernières nouvelles que
nous avons à notre disposition il
semblerait que sur le mécanisme
d'évaluation c'est un autre sujet que
l'établissement des comptes des
frontières intérieures la décision
finalement échappera totalement au
parlement européen qui ne seraient plus
qu'au législateur par une décision
unilatérale des états membres donc je
vous passe les détails du changement de
base juridique c'est un peu compliqué
mais on passerait d'une base juridique
qui associerait le parlement à ce
mécanisme d'évaluation à une base
juridique qui l'écarterait totalement
c'est institutionnellement extrêmement
désagréable et je pense qu'il y aura des
réactions extrêmement forte de tous les
partis politiques et de l'institution
parlementaire
alors avant même la réforme de schengen
il ya un état en europe qui ces jours-ci
rétabli
les contrôles aux frontières il s'agit
de la pologne puisque la pologne
accueille avec l'ukraine
l'euro 2012 de football
et on sait qu en ukraine il ya
évidemment des soucis que cet euro de
football a d'ailleurs été boycotté par
un grand nombre de dirigeants européens
on va en reparler dans un instant je
vous propose juste de regarder ce
reportage malade et emprisonnés l'ancien
chef du gouvernement ioulia timochenko
affirme même avoir été frappé par des
gardiens elle l'a écrit dans une lettre
lue par son avocat
j'ai reçu un coup violent dans le ventre
mes bras et mes jambes ont été tordus
j'ai été emmenée dehors dans cet état
j'ai pensé qu'il s'agissait là des
dernières minutes de ma vie pour la
fille de l'opposante ukrainienne la
situation de sa mère n'est pas un cas
isolé
elle a été mise à l'écart de la vie
politique sont ne pas empêcher le
président ianoukovitch de s'enrichir
personnellement
c'est partisans maltraite aujourd'hui
non seulement ma mère mais aussi une
douzaine d'autres prisonniers politiques
quatre d'entre eux ont besoin
d'assistance médicale et de soins à
quelques jours du début de l'euro
la question du boycott est sur toutes
les lèvres mais le premier ministre
polonais donald tusk prend les choses
avec humour notre vice-président du
parlement européen il ya sec
protasiewicz a pu parler directement
avec ioulia timochenko elle lui a dit
qu'elle même ne souhaitait pas que
l'euro de football soit boycotté cette
affaire se réglera sans conflit j'en
suis convaincu
la chancelière merkel vient de me dire
qu'il fallait trouver un terrain
d'entente
parce qu'elle a bien l'intention
d'assister au match
alors voilà ce que disent les
télévisions européennes sur l'euro de
football et en particulier les aspects
de privation de liberté de madame
timochenko donc en ukraine qu est ce qui
se dit ici au parlement européen est ce
que est ce que le les parlementaires
sont choqués par ce qui se passe en
ukraine
oui on l'a fait savoir au travers d'une
résolution qui demande formellement que
les personnes dites représentatives des
personnalités politiques qui
souhaiteraient se déplacer pour aller
assister au match de l'euro puisse faire
savoir qu'ils sont au courant de la
situation à la fois de madame timochenko
mais aussi d'autres prisonniers liés à
des faits politiques donc d'abord faire
savoir qu'on est au courant ensuite ne
pas forcément assister c'est une
position finalement que le gouvernement
français a pris puisque madame
fourneyron ministre des sports a indiqué
qu'il n'aurait pas de représentant du
gouvernement français
les eurodéputés vont s'y rendre écoutez
sans doute certains ailerons et
vis-à-vis de ce que je vous disais tout
à l'heure
peut-être que leur rôle c'est
effectivement de faire savoir qu'ils
sont au courant qu'ils savent que les
droits humains sont menacés que la
situation de madame timochenko et de
certains de ses collègues n'est pas une
situation agréable qu'il faut que ceci
est accès à un avocat qu'ils aient accès
à un procès correct donc c'est tout cet
enjeu de communication et de visibilité
qui est en jeu par la présence de
certaines personnalités si l on met ce
qu'il n'aurait pas été geste fort de
dire aucun eurodéputé ne se rendra à
l'euro de football
à partir du moment où ils respectent
cette prise de parole qui est la prise
de parole du parlement de visite
éviter des enjeux je crois qu'on peut
difficilement empêcher des amateurs de
football et je sais qu'il y en a
certains qui sont très accroché 2 6 1
donc l'idée c'est vraiment d'être
visible sur cet enjeu est visible pour
certains on aurait pu dire la même chose
pour les membres des gouvernements
français par exemple qui sont fanas de
football et qui qui aurait pu dire voilà
le côté de football est plus fort que le
gérant leur frustration de participation
au match je pense aisément mais je crois
que l'option qui a été prise et une
bonne option assez ferme et qui montre
bien qu'on ne transige pas avec un
certain nombre de droits notamment les
robinets est ce que le parlement
européen à un moyen d'action pour ce qui
se passe
programme timochenko est ce qu'il ya une
possibilité véritablement que bell soit
libéré tout simplement
le parlement européen a déjà agi
notamment à travers au travers de son
président puisque nous avons réussi il a
réussi à obtenir qu'un médecin puisse la
voir parce qu'ils y compris des faits
très graves a légué est éprouvée de
violence à son égard donc il a réussi
déjà à faire en sorte qu'un médecin soit
là les perspectives c'est que
effectivement eu des accès 1 à la
cassation parce qu'elle fait une
cassation sur son procès qu'elle est
accès à un procès correct que les
élections futures soit surveillé qu'il y
ait de nouveau des relations plus
confiants contre lui oignons européenne
et l'ukraine parce qu'il ya quand même
un certain nombre d'enjeux notamment
avec l'accord d'association est en train
de se négocier si vidéo merci beaucoup
d'avoir accepté notre invitation dans
europe hebdo
cette émission se poursuit on va
retrouver kathia gilder et son invité et
qui vont en particulier nous parler des
suites des différends tremblement de
terre en italie je vous propose de
regarder d'abord ce reportage qui a été
fait à l'aquila où il ya vu un
tremblement de terre il ya trois ans
un reportage signé paul bouffard
une cité médiévale dévastés comme
bombarder au coeur des abruzzes dans ses
rues vivait plus de 70000 personnes
aujourd'hui
l'aquila est une ville fantôme
3h32 du matin le 6 avril 2009
l'aquila est touchée par un tremblement
de terre de magnitude 6,3 sur l'échelle
de richter
la ville est totalement détruite 309
morts et plus de cinquante cinq mille
personnes évacuées à quelques kilomètres
du centre ville
l'urgence a fait pousser ses résidences
champignons trois ans après vingt-sept
mille victimes ne sont pas rentrées chez
elles
les sinistrés sont hébergées dans ces
maisons en bois
juliano et sa femme ont tout perdu
aujourd'hui ils vivent au milieu de
nulle part
rien ici pas de magasin il faut aller
loin
au milieu de ça il n'y a rien il n'ya
que nous le maintien des magasins non
donc il n'y a rien j'en avais il ferait
du bon business
je n'ai rien
ce policier à la retraite compte chaque
jour loin de chez lui
je suis ici depuis 23 février 2010 ça
fait deux ans et trois mois à 78 ans
juliano se sont coupés du monde
abandonné des autorités pourtant ils
espèrent toujours reconstruire sa maison
et sa vie à tous on attend de rentrer
chez nous ça sera un soulagement
psychologique pour voir où tu étais
baptisé marié où tu as eu des enfants
ont tué devenu grand père c'est la chose
la plus importante
tout ici tu as un toit sur la tête mais
ça s'arrête là
la vie d'avant elle n'existe plus tu ne
pourras plus avoir moi personnellement
je prévois de rester ici encore quatre
ou cinq ans avant que la reconstruction
soit terminé pour nous ça serait bien
ici on n'est pas malheureux mais bon
trois années se sont écoulées depuis la
catastrophe
le coeur historique en ruine et
inhabitables dans cette zone rouge
surveillé par l'armée
personne ne peut circuler au détour
d'une ruelle abandonné un irréductible
fausto corti il préside l'association de
sauvegarde du patrimoine local et pour
lui pas question de laisser tomber sa
cité au chômage
c'est ma maison c'est le jardin de chez
moi
dans sa maison la reconstruction n'a pas
commencé la vaisselle du soir du séisme
est encore dans l'évier
au lendemain du drame la commission
européenne verse une aide de près de 500
millions d'euros à l'état italien
une aide qui n'a pas servi à la
reconstruction
le problème principal aujourd'hui c'est
que l'argent reste dans les caisses de
l'état
à cause de la bureaucratie italienne qui
bloque la reconstruction
surtout ici dans le centre historique
trois ans après le tremblement de terre
on en est encore au stade des projets à
l'époque dans l'urgence le gouvernement
berlusconi sécurisé les bâtiments
endommagés opération trop coûteuse pour
les architectes et urbanistes la mairie
de la corrida et l'administration
générale a dépensé 400 millions d'euros
dans le processus de sédimentation elles
ont employé des milliers d'ouvriers des
centaines d'ingénieurs sans même savoir
s'il était possible de sauver tel ou tel
bâtiment ou s'il fallait des faits
aujourd'hui les autorités sont encore
dans l'urgence et se contente de
financer l'aide aux victimes de l'argent
gaspillé selon fausto corti plus la
reconstruction durera longtemps plus
l'argent partira dans l'assistance du
registre personnes tous les habitants de
l'aquila sont assistés reçoivent de
l'argent public
mais cet argent devrait plutôt servir à
reconstruire
au final plus on est assistée - il y
aura de fonds pour sauver des vies le 18
mai dernier élections municipales le
maire massimo cialente et est reconduit
lors d'une conférence de presse il
présente son plan de réhabilitation
mais reste un problème un homme un
opposant au maire le commissaire du
gouvernement pour la reconstruction
depuis la nomination de ce proche de
silvio berlusconi
au lendemain du séisme les fonds
n'arrivent plus aucun chantier n'a vu le
jour
le gouvernement dit qu'il ya de l'argent
il continue de le dire
alors si c'est vrai donnez-nous les
ressources pour avancer
s'il n'y a rien il faut nous le dire
c'est un acte de responsabilité de lui
dire pourtant malgré le sentiment
d'abandon les habitants petit à petit se
réapproprie les ruines il y à quelques
lieux de vie avec des commerçants qui se
réinstallent qui ont repris leurs
activités
je les appelle les pionniers mais au
final c'est vrai que la ville a du mal à
en face à la lenteur des autorités
italiennes
la municipalité de l'aquila veut devenir
capitale européenne de la culture en
une dernière chance pour espérer un
sursaut et la reconstruction
retour à bruxelles pour commenter ce
reportage un eurodéputé italien est avec
nous rosario crocetta bonjour alors vous
êtes une grande figure de la lutte
contre la mafia dans votre pays on vous
a même suivi dans ce combat qui est le
combat de votre vie on parle aujourd'hui
d'un autre fléau qui touche l'italie
cette terre qui tremble souvent trois
ans après la tragédie pourtant on le
voit avec ce reportage de paul bouffard
la ville est encore dans dans l'est dans
les ruines avec même des appartements en
friche est ce que c'est normal
oui le label made woman était la chose
que des rues de qpr demirbas réalité
parce que c'est quelque chose de coeur
pas seulement créé va créer des victimes
des morts du panic d'entre les gens la
perdre moi j'ai pour une baignade et
j'habitais dans une zone de l'italie
pourrait - où il y avait des
tremblements de terre et chaque nuit je
sortis de la maison pour vie pour rester
au dehors dans la voiture avec les
sahraouis et j'ai vécu c'était se tester
via ce site que cela qui est plus
terrible
et après parce que après lesquels elle
la paire est super et on entend
quelqu'un noyage dans sa ville et
trouvent des pièges et après j'étais par
terre un coin nous a passé sa jeunesse
et monuments un quartier parce que les
villes ne sont pas seulement des
constructions de bierne
mais la ville est une agrégation humain
de couture et le sonos les places en
planque une histoire alors ça va devenir
un terrible parce que les gens se
trouvent privés des solidarités ils
n'ont pas de romy d'éditer plus
l'arrivée je suis quelqu'un qui habite
dans une baraque et que l'appât héros
vie normale alors il faut faire des
choses complètement différentes
on voit bien que pour l'instant tout ça
c'est bloquer la ville a du mal à se
reconstruire pourtant de l'argent
européen a été donnée près de 500
millions d'euros où est passé cet argent
et pourquoi est ce qui n'a pas permis de
faire un nom le problème de
l'utilisation de l'argent en italie
c'est quelque chose
impressionnant parce que les l'italie
d'un d'aller dormir 4è et catane et n'a
pas utilisé même plus que les 30 % de
l'argent qui arrivait de l'europe donc
qu' il y avait des responsabilités du
gouvernement qui est passé sur ce amelia
de même des régions que ça m'a
complètement incapable d'affronter le
problème le problème de la de la
globalisation comme on dit à même de la
construction européenne
parce que où il ya des administrations
ou les fonctionnaires ne connaît pas
l'anglais ne connaît pas le français
comme il va participer aux appels
européens mais il ne connaît pas ils ne
suivent pas l'europe
alors il y avait même une bureaucratie
qui comptera ce qui a déroulé tellement
tellement bureaucratique des lois
pratiques en italie le sait la loi est
top et plutôt que favoriser les
développements le bloc alors il faut il
faut changer aux tic et je crois qu'il
faut même des dérégulations qu'est ce
qu'il faut faire à l'italie son nom la
famille terre et les roule pour la
facilitation de déconstruction du
développement et les roule pour
contrôler que cette développement à
vienne dans la légalité et qui ne
m'arrive pas dans les poches des
et décembre politique économique à
cordoue et qui sont agents de corruption
et même de la mafia on a il ya eu une
affaire il ya plus d'un an ou plusieurs
responsables de la mafia napolitaine ont
été arrêtés ils ont été soupçonnés
d'avoir monté des sociétés fictives et
d'avoir infiltré cette reconstitution il
ya une et puissant de traiter louis
bouillot registre à sion en lévitation
téléphoniques de la police pendant la
nuit du tout mouvement de terre de
l'aquila qui lie à décembre d'affaires
frais liés à la politique du parti de
berlusconi qui est les kilos ouvrir une
bouteille de champagne in et ils l'ont
dit a look et des gens il est entré de
mourir il est il est on dit ont
maintenant commencé les affaires et ça
c'est terrible
il y a des gens que considéré un
doublement de terre et une inondation ou
catastrophe quelque chose qui peut être
l'occasion pour les affaires même par
exemple dans le cas de l'aquila
nous avons découvrir qu'il ya une école
ou leur maison des étudiants des soirs
où sont mortes soit sans gêne 60 garçons
et filles dansaient nuit et alors qu'est
une construction nouvelle que doit durer
six ans en minimes au est tombé avec un
doublement de terre qui avait évoqué ce
qu'ont à découvrir qu'il y avait les
saumons des policiers ça veut dire et la
corruption de la mafia alors il n'y a
pas seulement les responsabilités de la
nature ben là la cause de la nature mais
bien des responsabilités de cette rue
même deux sur la has ans de prévention
parce que villiers comme l'italie en
ciel comme l'italie a besoin des
subventions mais même les nouvelles
constructions
il y a le poids de la corruption et de
la main
bien que nous vendent pas si efficace la
prévention contre ces choses alors je
vous propose d'écouter le maire de
l'aquila qui a une question à poser une
question qui s'adresse aux autorités
européennes alors écouter ses doléances
pour lui répondre et juste après lequel
le lien open je demande à l'union
européenne à fournir une assistance mais
surtout d'avoir un regard particulier
sur les zones italienne ça touchés par
les séismes sar pour la plus là mais
aussi pour les autres tremblements de
terre il faudrait trouver des mesures
qui y est c'est zones frappées par les
catastrophes naturelles et en
particulier les grandes villes comme
l'aquila ville risque de se retrouver
rapidement dans une situation de
pauvreté
voilà rosario crocetta qu'est ce que
l'union européenne peut faire contre les
catastrophes naturelles par nature
imprévisibles les mêmes raisons parce
que il y avait par exemple des villes
des régions qu'on subit un tremblement
de terre et sont obligés à respecter le
pacte de stabilité
alors ça veut dire que même si l'offre
de l'argent il ne peut pas y penser
parce que entre dans le pacte de
stabilité
et après ils sont pénalisés la deuxième
il faut concéder au maire à l'eau qui on
donne de l'argent de procédure les ssp
social spéciale pour faire vite les
travaux parce que ça c'est dans le
respect de la loi bien sûr des
procédures qui permettent des individus
et facilement des peuples pour laquelle
à 3 sièges
pourquoi ne donnez pas l'autorisation à
la mairie de deux de l'aquila de faire
de la ville une zone franche urbaine et
les europe pdp dit plutôt qu'une egis à
la ville pour bouffer mais impliquerait
de changer la loi italienne
sessegnon c'est une tradition de la loi
italienne la zone franche urbaine la
question de la dette de la zone schengen
beaucoup de fois nous savons oui en la
position de la commission européenne et
par qui parce que dire sinon qu'on le
pensait dans quelque chose de
l'aquitaine
alors ça veut dire que c'est là à la
possibilité de super héros
edith bongo grandissante des incas
particulière où il y a des victimes où
il ya des gens qui ne paient pas pu
repartir comme pour les inondations ou
les achats dans des cas comme ça il faut
et après je crois qu'il faut prix
évidemment infante extraordinaire pour
tous ces cas là parce que dans une place
aux plats ou les innovations cette année
puisqu'on a fait l'europe lyon donc il
faudrait une force européenne de
sécurité civile qui est demandée depuis
des années qu'on ne voient toujours pas
venir vous vous demandez vous aussi oui
oui je m'aime gg une tension de 2 pb
avec d autres députés
vous cherchez de faire une déclaration
écrit sous ce cas là et après il ya une
autre chose
les citoyennes ils n'ont pas selon la
loi italienne et selon la loi de
beaucoup d'états européennes en cas de
catastrophe naturelle heynckes des
révoltes de faire une assurance pour sa
maison au pouce et bien parce que les
assurances n'assure pas alors il faut
faire une déclaration de la commission
ou non on a directive directives de la
conscience qui obligeait les essieux et
l'esa et les compagnies d'assurance
européennes assurer les gens même vous
ce risque-là merci beaucoup
rosario crocetta si on arrive au terme
de cette émission je vous souhaite une
très bonne suite de programmes rendez
vous la semaine prochaine à strasbourg
à